in Fall River Massachusetts you will
find a sandwich with Chinese roots and
American stylings mostly noodles
bookended by hamburger buns the chow
mein sandwich is unique in its taste
texture and history my name is Regina MA
I'm a co-owner of me some restaurants in
Fall River Massachusetts
forever is known for the chow mein
sandwich also Mo Lagasse
a chow mein sandwich for me sums me some
restaurant isn't the only place in Fall
River that makes a chow mein sandwich
but theirs is considered the best tell
me sandwich is crispy if I knew we put
on top of the hamburger bun with the
brown gravy over it
the Chinese sandwich what to this
country in early 1900 by the Chinese
immigrant Chinese immigrants settled in
Fall River because of the area's textile
factories and they brought their unique
noodles with them factory workers of all
kinds fell in love with the inexpensive
meal and a beloved regional specialty
was born Tomi sandwich actually created
by accident when people eat the chow
mein they'll use the bread to soak up
the gravy then one day they run out of
the bread so that's why they serve them
the hamburger bun
because the popularity of the chiming
sandwich we go to a lot of hamburger bun
and a lot of Reiner ooh in a week we go
to about 200 pound of new people come
from all over the United States to try
this charming sandwich we have people
come from Chicago Hawaii one customer
come from Tokyo because they saw that in
an Internet
[Music]
this restaurant is palpable American
dream for us forward is our home full
always bring people happiness people be
kind to us they welcoming us into this
area and support us for many years I
don't have my customer as customer
they're more like my friend and family
[Music]